the Lakota only acquired the Black Hills
in 1776 and the way they acquired it was
by moving in from Minnesota and
conquering the Cheyenne so should the US
government pay a billion dollars to the
Lakota because we took Lakota land or
should we pay a billion dollars to the
cheyen because the Lakota took cheyen
land well hold on hold on just a second
here the Cheyenne it turns out they did
not Sprout out of the ground either the
Cheyenne only moved in during the 18th
century before that the land had
belonged to the kioa and the crow before
the oji Indians started taking Land from
the Lakota impelling the cheyen to start
taking Land from the kioa and the crow
before the Lakota came in and took the
land from the cheyen before the US took
the land from the
Lakota wow I'm dizzy how exactly do the
anti-colonial activists suggest that we
decolonize the Black Hills if anyone has
an answer to how exactly we're going to
decolonize that land I'm open to it